hi dina hi martin how are you doing
just fine thanks what are we working on
today
well my friend holly works for a large
marketing research firm
she uses a cloud function to write to
her cloud sql database
she's concerned that somebody will find
her http cloud function
and access her database she should use
an
ingress controlled function that way no
one on the public internet can access
the function
we can set it up with a virtual private
cloud connector
[Music]
an ingress controlled function sounds
great the new project she's working on
is collecting flavor research for a
candy company
she has a cloud run front end that sends
the vote data to a cloud function
which parses and validates the data then
it sends the data to another cloud
function called
write to db which inserts the row into
the cloud sql table
so here is the app and we can vote for
kale margarita or watermelon
kale lollipops dina is this a california
company
i think so i think it would be
watermelon for me
kale's winning oh no
holly really wants to ensure that there
are zero fraudulent rights to her
database in the future
how do we achieve this well she should
update the settings on her
right to db function to only allow
internal traffic
this will exclude any network requests
not originating from the same project
okay so i have my cloud function here
and i'm clicking edit
um i scroll down i see variables
networking and advanced settings is that
where
networking yeah okay networking and
advanced environment variables or
connections
internal um set it to internal traffic
okay allowance around traffic
okay uh let's try voting
all right
it's not working it's a 500 error that's
actually good
that means that the network settings are
working we
updated the function right to db to only
accept
private connections but the function can
devote
isn't sending its data through a private
connector
now we need to ensure that candyvote is
using a vpc connector
to call right to db but first you need
to create the vpc connector
okay let's do it okay so i'm
in the vpc network settings
i'm going to serverless vpc access
and i am clicking create connector
yeah name candy vote connector
that's right it sounds great yeah
network
default yep defaults are our friends
here
ip range i i really don't know but they
give an example so i'm just going to use
that example
yeah let's go with the defaults okay and
create
okay i have a vp c connector what do i
do with it
excellent now you go and update the
candy vote function
to use that vpc connector this means
that any outgoing requests
from the candy vote function like calls
to the right to db function
they will go through the vpc connector
okay so when i go in and i look at the
connections
okay right here it says egress settings
and then
i select candy connector excellent
um and route all traffic through the vpc
connector
yeah all of it okay
and i've deployed let's try voting again
yeah what should i vote for
uh maybe margarita this time
it works ah good well we need to gang up
on those kale people
if you wanted to make it even a little
more secure you could
update the cloud sql database to be a
private ip
cloud sql so currently the right to db
function only accepts internal traffic
but if we update the outgoing request
to go through a vpc connector we could
connect
to the private ip cloud sql
what this means is that even if somebody
has the sql database's root password
they can't connect to it from the public
internet that sounds like a really good
use of our network settings
excellent i can't wait for my favorite
new flavor of lollipop
i hope the kale lollipop counts towards
my daily servings of vegetables
[Music]